turning this robot on
is all that hong yi lu needs to do
before it turns its attention to him
the researcher at sweden's royal
institute of technology has designed a
breakthrough in how people and robots
work together
his robot can recognize and even predict
his gestures and wishes
such as pass me that spanner instead of
slowing down or stopping if a human gets
too close
basically i want a robot to work with me
similar as a human co-worker
to hand me over the right tool at right
time at right location
which is not happening right now in the
industry so i wanted to
break the barrier between human robot
the barrier is reduced by a scanner that
works out each person's body structure
to prevent any collision between metal
and flesh
a robot that can predict a human's
actions and adapt to them can be a game
changer in this
field but sweden's success with this
kind of technology
is also down to how humans have adapted
to robots
swedish heavy industry already makes
wide use of robotics
workers fears of being replaced are
eased at least in theory by a generous
welfare state
and strong trades unions that insist on
retraining when a machine takes over
this office in malmo may not look like a
hive of robotic activity but behind the
scenes
or rather in the cloud robot reporters
are doing the work of thousands of
journalists
turning data on sports matches real
estate weather and traffic
accidents into written reports it would
be fair to say that we have
maybe caused a couple of of journalists
jobs to to disappear
but that is only because they were doing
stuff that machines can do better
we do the simple repetitive reporting
they can do the more qualitative
high-level
reporting the robotic scoops are ready
for the morning edition of the barometer
newspaper in calmer and at dozens of
national and local titles across sweden
the robot is actually one of our most
contributing
reporters it's all about having more
content
to offer to our readers back at the lab
in stockholm
the goal is for robot human relations to
be about collaboration not competition
if we can introduce a robot to help a
human operator
together they form a new team they can
be more productive
in the industrial setting robots may now
be able to avoid
harming a human's body but it might take
a very hard-headed employee
to stop worrying about robots harming
their job prospects
paul reese al jazeera stockholm